merci beaucoup pauline on retrouve tout
à l'heure pour l'heure c'est l'heure de
l'invité de paris direct
notre invité ce matin guillaume perrier
journaliste au service international de
l'hebdomadaire le point et spécialiste
de la turquie merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin on
vous reçoit pas ce que vous venez de
cosigner se livre avec une autre
journaliste spécialiste de la turquie
leurs marchands les loups m la brume ça
vient de sortir aux aux éditions grasset
est une longue enquête très fouillée à
travers paris berlin palerme bruxelles
sur l'activisme souterrains clandestins
de la turquie et deux de ses services
secrets aidé par une myriade de groupes
des services turquie n'hésite pas à
mener des attentats ciblés des
assassinats ciblés en europe avec dans
l'ombre ou plutôt dans cette brume le
président recep tayyip erdogan d'abord
un mot à mot de ses services tueur que
le grand public connaît peu qu'est ce
que le imiter le mythe et ses
ramifications
oui le mythe c'est une désorganisation
de renseignements les plus puissantes au
monde aujourd'hui avec plus de 6000
employés à travers le monde un activisme
une présence sur les cinq continents à
l'image
du déploiement
diplomatique tous azimuts de la turquie
ces dernières années je dirais donc
le mythe il faut savoir qu'il est dirigé
depuis plus de douze ans maintenant par
hakan fidan qui est un technocrate turcs
eux très proche de redjep tayyip erdogan
verdone l'appelle ma boîte noire donc ça
vous donne déjà un petit peu une idée du
rôle que peut jouer ce service est donc
c'est un petit peu le gardien des
secrets du régime est le bras armé de la
diplomatie d'erdogan aujourd'hui à
l'étranger qui a été réformé et qui est
noyauté en gros par par les
nationalistes turcs samura alors qui a
été réformé et puis comme toutes les
administrations clé je dirais de la
bureaucratie turque depuis quelques
années qui a été abondamment purger
reprise en main par par les proches de
rajab cyberdouane est effectivement
aujourd'hui au sein duquel
les groupes les plus nationalistes
ont repris le dessus ça n'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau parce que dans
l'histoire la longue histoire du mythe
il ya aussi finalement un lien très fort
historique avec l'extrême droite
ultranationalistes turcs ce qu'on
appelle les loups gris
également avec la mafia
qui a toujours été de près ou de loin
très très imbriqué dans c dans ses
opérations dans les années 80-90 déjà le
mythe mener des assassinats ciblés en
europe y compris en france y compris en
plein paris contre des militants ou des
terroristes arméniens ou kurde
aujourd'hui on voit si vous voulez ses
réseaux ses méthodes se réactive et
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu
ardoines depuis le coup d'état manqué de
l'été 2016 a été obligé de reprendre en
main tout l'appareil d'état tout
l'appareil sécuritaire d'une façon
extrêmement ferme à rien voilà une vraie
paranoïa souvent justifiées il y avait
effectivement
des complots contre lui au sein des
forces armées et probablement au sein
des services secrets et donc il a fait
du mythe sa garde rapprochée sa garde
prétorienne en quelque sorte et
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment l'institution
qui se trouve au coeur de du déploiement
stratégique de la turquie dans quai des
cibles de choix il ya notamment l'ailé
proche du prédicateur fait d'yquem
fethullah gulen qui a un réseau à
travers le monde et qui est accusé par
red star de nba derrière le le coup
d'état qui a tenté de le destituer puis
aussi les kurdes et avec des attentes a
donc ciblé en europe je pense notamment
à l'attentât de paris dont vous parlez
beaucoup ces trois militante kurde
assassiné en plein paris en 2013
l'enquète a été semée d'embûches entre
avait notamment par le secret défense
que sait-on aujourd'hui de l'assassinât
de ces trois femmes en plein paris c'est
assez simple ces trois femmes donc
étaient trois militants du pkk sakineh
johnsons était là la principale cible
était vraiment à une personnalité
extrêmement importante au sein de
fondatrices du parti des travailleurs du
kurdistan il était avec abdullah ocalan
s'approche de lui c'est ça dès 1978 et
donc c'est la fondatrice de la branche
des femmes au sein du pkk on sait que
les femmes enfin de lui il ya une
certaine vision de l'égalité
hommes-femmes au sein de ce mouvement
kurde et qu' elle est à l'origine de la
création de la branche féminine de la
guérilla donc c'est quelqu'un qui a une
aura une un charisme extrêmement
important dans le mouvement on étudie
ces textes enfin voilà donc cet
assassinat a été un choc extrêmement
important d'autant plus qu' il faut
remettre ça dans le contexte intervient
en janvier 2013 ça va bientôt faire dix
ans à l'époque la turquie négocier avec
le pkk essayer de régler par des
négociations secrètes dans lequel le
mythe était impliqué ce conflit vieux de
40 ans qui a fait plus de 40 mille morts
donc il y avait une volonté politique
de résoudre par le dialogue c'est cette
question qui a été torpillé par cet
assassinat et donc c'est ça qu'on
s'aperçoit c'est de ça qu'on s'aperçoit
aujourd'hui c'est que cet assassinat
commandité par des gens au sein des
services secrets salle enquête a peu à
peu fait apparaître cette cette vérité
comme les tours couverts la câble qui
morte avant son procès alors l'assassin
a été attrapé
avec des preuves de son méfait
avait utilisé un pistolet à silencieux
trois balles pour chaque victime quelque
chose d'extrêmement professionnels
il a été arrêté il a passé plusieurs
mois en prison un procès a été une
une procédure judiciaire a été ouverte
et 7 cet homme ce jeune homme était
atteint d'une tumeur au cerveau
incurable et il est mort en prison avant
d'avoir pu être jugée s'est aperçu
évidemment après que se profilent avait
pas été choisi au hasard et que c'était
bien pour ça qu'il avait été choisi pour
exécuter ce crime les services secrets
turcs eux savaient parfaitement quel
était son état de santé et c'était
c'était un atout pour eux évidemment
la procédure s'est poursuivie enfin il
ya juste intentions qui a repris le
dossier alors voilà le le le procès
s'est arrêté avec la mort du principal
coupable mais effectivement il ya
plusieurs mois le un nouveau juge
d'instruction a ouvert une enquête
sur la base des nouveaux éléments qui
qu'il contenait pour essayer de
retrouver les commanditaires et les
commanditaires sont jamais très loin des
services secrets turcs ont approuvé par
une autre enquête et différents
documents puisqu'on a eu accès à la fois
au service eau au dossier judiciaire
français belges mais également turc on a
eu accès a effectivement des documents
qui montrent de manière implacable les
échanges ou l'absence de coopération
entre les différentes justice la gêne
qui s'installe progressivement y compris
entre le juge d'instruction français et
les services de renseignement français
qui on le voit très vite coopèrent assez
peu avec l'inquiète oui parce qu'en fait
donc le juge d'instruction qui va
reprendre le dossier va se heurter à des
documents classés secret défense qui
avait hard et c'est à dire dont une
grande partie ont été effacées mais on
apprend quand même grâce aux documents
vous avez vu vous même que les
renseignements français avaient
justement rédigé une note sur la
principale cible de cet assassinat
deux jours avant voilà deux jours avant
une très détaillée donc sur sakineh d'un
jeune joggeuse ce personnage dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure donc
ça ne constitue pas une preuve mais on
peut pas s'empêcher de penser que
les services français pouvait être au
courant de quelque chose qui se prépare
est du moins laissé peut-être faire et
ont peut-être laissé faire sept
personnes étaient sous surveillance on
le sait il le lieu de l'assassinât était
également sous la surveillance des
services français on le sait puisque les
allées et venues dans ses bureaux
étaient largement documentée dans
différents rapports au cours des mois
précédents il ya donc effectivement un
gros doute et puis pourquoi avoir
censuré totalement cette note sur
sakineh jones aux si elle ne comporte
pas d'élément gênons pour pour les
services s'ils savaient plus résoudre
une partie de l'anc est pourquoi avoir
jusqu'à aujourd'hui cacher ses preuves
au juge d'instruction dans ce livre on
revenait aussi sur un projet
d'assassinât contre une parlementaire
autrichienne d'origine kurde une
militante de la cause kurde mais l'homme
qui ne vais la tuer elle n'a pas fait il
s'est rendu de lui même à la police
il a été en prison depuis le vit caché
en sicile où il se sent protégé par l'
influence de la mafia vous l'avez
rencontré cet homme là lui ils
témoignent ils racontent un peu comment
tout cela fonctionne et comment
fonctionne le le mythe en coulisses
alors ça n'a pas été simple évidemment
quand cette affaire est sorti en
septembre j'ai enquêté de long sur sur 7
sur cette affaire parce que c'était un
cas unique si vous voulez pour pouvoir
expliquer ce sur quoi je travaillais
déjà depuis longtemps
donc j'ai retrouvé au bout de plusieurs
mois j'ai retrouvé la trace de cet homme
j'ai fini par le convaincre
de me voir je suis allé à palerme j'ai
fait 16 heures d'interviews avec lui sur
plusieurs jours
et évidemment
la parole de ce genre de témoin est
toujours à prendre avec toutes les
précautions possibles mais j'ai essayé
d'enquêté de recouper chacun des détails
qu'il a pu me donner certaines choses se
sont avérées invérifiables et sont pas
dans le livre d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
racontées mais un certain nombre de
choses nous met sur la piste si vous
voulez
des méthodes d'exécution du mythe de la
structure du mythe des rapports de
pouvoir au sein du mythe c'est ça qui
est intéressant aussi comme toutes les
institutions turques c'est une
institution qui est traversée par des
rivalités
différents clans qui se font la guerre
est ce que ça montre si vous voulez
cette brume un qu'on essaye de dissiper
un petit peu c'est aussi
l'expression d'une lutte de pouvoir
absolument féroce au sein des
institutions turques et que c'est le
signe d'un affaiblissement d'erdogan
tout ça depuis la tentative de coup
d'état son pouvoir s'est
considérablement affaibli s'est sentie
fragilisé à la fois par donc cette
contestation sein de l'armée
contestation dans la rue la crise
économique qui frappe la turquie de
plein fouet son sa popularité qui
s'érode année après année et alors que
la présidentielle et législatives par
dans approche sera ce sera au printemps
l'année prochaine sont sensé
effectivement être organisées des
élections pour le centenaire de la
république turque donc quelque chose de
très attendu par air douanes et tout ça
montre finalement que
il est obligé de
serrer la vis 1
autour d'eux d'institutions comme le
mythe de renforcer son pouvoir et sa
montre qu'il ya des rivalités qui
s'exprime et qu'il est obligé de
s'appuyer sur
les clans qui sont proches de l'extrême
droite c'est son principal allié
aujourd'hui au pouvoir c'est le parti
d'extrême droite le parti ultra
nationaliste mhp celui des loups gris
celui même qui qui s'avère être
extrêmement puissant au sein des
services secrets il est à la rechercher
ratchet et hyper douanes également
d'allier sur la scène internationale et
parfois on a un peu du mal à le suivre
et soufflent le chaud et le froid avec
les européens en proposant des alliances
puis en faisant la menace des migrants
syriens qui ont revenons en arrière en
se rapprochant de la russie puis en se
faisant à moitié la guerre en syrie on
se rabiboche ensuite c'est la même chose
avec l'arabie saoudite pour la faire
jamal razon giroud au début il ya une
brouille puis un rapprochement et même
un déplacement je crois sur place
d'où vient ce côté j'allais dire
girouette de recep tayyip erdogan qui
sont ses vrais alliés solides à
l'international y en a pas
il y en a pas je crois que le som cause
que vous appelez son côté girouette son
pragmatisme a longtemps été loué pour sa
et qu'aujourd'hui on en voit une
expression qui nous surprend mais
erdogan a toujours été comme ça c'est
toujours la manière dont il a gouverné
en interne comme à l'international et
donc ses vrais alliés sont ses ennemis
de demain et vice versa ça a toujours
été sa façon de fonctionner on parlait
de fethullah gulen ce prédicateur tout à
l'heure ça a été celui qui l'a porté au
pouvoir
aujourd'hui c'est un ennemi d'état
absolue
un chef terroriste
et c'est donc sur tous les sujets on
peut faire la même observation sur
l'europe sur israël sur la syrie
effectivement assad a été son frère
avant la guerre puis son pire ennemi est
aujourd'hui sont en train de se
réconcilier ce qui est dans la logique
des choses
d'ailleurs c'est le chef du mythe qui
est chargée de cette réconciliation avec
ali mamlouk chef des services de
sécurité syriens donc on voit là encore
les services secrets turcs qui sont au
coeur de cette diplomatie alors quelle
est la logique dans tout ça
je dirais qu'il faut voir erdogan comme
un pragmatique quelqu'un qui impose un
rapport de force permanent avec les
européens vous avez parlé de la question
des migrants l'anc est que nous menons
des montres ça aussi c'est à dire que la
surveillance de la diaspora l'entrisme
l'influent ce qui peut avoir sur le sol
européen c'est une manière aussi de
jouer ce rapport de force avec l'union
européenne on l'a vu aussi au moment du
débat sur l'entrée de la suède à l'otan
merci merci beaucoup guillaume pelletier
je rappelle que vous signez cette
enquête avec laure marchand les loups m
la brume c'est aux éditions grasset
recèlera si absolument passionnant merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin et merci à vous d'avoir choisi
paris direct on se retrouve dans un
instant
[Musique]